hello everyone and welcome to another
episode of alexa and friends
my name is jeff blankenberg and today i
get the opportunity to chat with yang
liu who's a principal scientist on the
alexa ai team uh so every once in a
while we get some great guests from our
amazon science organization and today is
not going to answer your questions
uh and today is no exception i am so
excited to have you here yang thank you
so much for joining
thank you jeff good morning
so uh one of the things that i like to
do and i know you've been uh warned
about this is that i like to ask a few
silly questions at the beginning of
these interviews to give people a little
idea about who you are and maybe some
perspectives you have on things so the
first question that i like to ask and uh
for anyone that may watch future
episodes of this i do have intentions to
switch this up and change the questions
but for today these might seem familiar
so the first question is uh
we've had lots and lots of superhero
movies and comic book characters
uh are very very popular these days
so i'm curious if you could pick a
superhero power for yourself
what do you think you might pick
um actually i was walking somewhere
watching some of your episodes before
and i was thinking um when my kids
sometimes play this but you can have a
wish and what's your wish for the game
when one of them often said
can i wish for more wishes so my first
reaction is can i use my super power to
have more superpowers whatever super
strength your supervision and those
kinds of things
but that's just joking uh i i know i can
only have one and if i can be great
maybe two for now uh the first one i i
really hope i can have the superpower to
stop the pandemic uh right now and maybe
that's one for everybody not just for me
um and the other one is the real one and
that's probably more related to what
we're going to talk about today um i
often hope um i can have a superpower to
kind of
formulate more my thoughts
into a good language a good way to
express to different audience like when
i was talking to you about some
technical stuff that's probably
um a different way from talking to my
colleague about the same content and
same thing when my talk
when i was talking to my christmas
sometimes i hope oh i should use the
language that's good for them um yeah so
like
formulating those random thoughts or
talking points into
what um good way that's interesting
i like that the way the way that that
occurs to me is it feels like language
language based empathy
right you are you're able to recognize
and identify the best way to explain
something or communicate with someone
um and then be naturally able to do that
in whatever words or language even
potentially
uh that you would best be suited for i
love that that's uh
i like that and so that's an easy one to
talk about how you would use it for good
that's something else that i like to
focus on with these super power
questions
most or somebody wants to have super
strength or speed or flight or something
yeah that's very natural
it's it's very easy to understand how
you might use those for evil
um but i always like to ask how you use
it for good but this one's pretty clear
um
this one i guess
share yourself for evil
even um
um factually incorrect the information
and then you will not do any good right
whether you can use what this kind of
thing maybe you will talk more more
about this whether when you talk about
these chatbots and all the language
generation techniques
yeah
agreed man uh this is a this is a good
one i really like that uh all right my
second question i have to tell you a
little story first uh and then i need
you to make a choice
so
i want you to imagine you're walking
through a large city and you need to get
one block over and one large city block
can take a while to walk all the way
around
and so you note on your way that there's
an alley that leads directly where you'd
like to go it's a bright sunny day
there's nothing to suggest that there
would be any trouble going down this
alley so you you walk down the alley
towards your destination
uh and as you get about halfway down you
notice that a large
horse-sized chicken
uh unfortunately i'm sorry why did i say
chicken
emerges at the end that you're heading
towards that's a very very large duck
about the size of a horse
um and as would be natural you say i'm
not going that way that looks insane i'm
going to turn around and go the other
way uh take the longer route only to
find out that that end has been closed
by 100
duck-sized horses tiny horses
now you're probably going to be in some
sort of scuffle or fight as you go
through this but i'd love to know which
direction you would go and why you think
you might have a better success going
that direction
do they do they look cute or aggressive
they're more on the aggressive side than
they are okay yeah yeah then that's
different from whether playing with cute
animals um i don't know i guess my
decision probably will be whether based
on my
at that particular moment but now if i
can do more logical thinking i think i
will go with the one horse says the
weather dog um i just feel as weather
you have 100 uh uh duck says the horses
they they they form they can draw forces
they form like an army and then it's
kind of hard to fight with those so i'll
go with one and the horse size seems
doable manageable
i have to say i've asked this question
of
more than two dozen people at this point
and you were the first person to suggest
that the small horses could team up
uh like would would like fight in unison
right where they're actually working
together yeah first person to suggest
that and i think you're right i think
that like if we have a world where there
are tiny horses what's to say that they
couldn't also uh be communicating and
form an attack
yeah
really they won't use their language
maybe i can express my thoughts what
they let me go through and then they
will hear what they in their uh language
and then they can then
yeah yeah and it's nice that you brought
your superpower into this because it
doesn't just apply to humans
uh it would be nice to be able to tell
my dog exactly what i need her to do
yeah get her to contribute around the
house a little bit instead of just
leaving her toys everywhere right that
would be great
uh all right well that that was
fantastic thanks for the fun there at
the beginning uh the next thing that i
like to do and this is one of our
audience's favorite parts is to kind of
understand where you came from and and
how you got to where you are today so i
mentioned that you're a principal
scientist on the alexa ai team
and we'll get into that more a bit later
but what i'd like to know initially is
kind of what your origin story is to go
back to the superhero kind of stories
where did you come from where did you go
to school where did you grow up um
i i'd love the long version of kind of
where you
where you started and how you got to
where you are today
yeah we can we can do the long version
all right um yeah a lot of things when
now looking back it seems they happen
naturally
what i didn't do very what deliberated
what thinking decision but we can go
through the story maybe they are not so
interesting
um so i grew up in china uh and then
went to uh qinghua university in beijing
um back then when you went to uh
university then you need to choose a
major same thing now you still need a
chosen major um so i majored in
electrical engineering
that's kind of my parents decision um
and i still remember when i
was deciding should i do computer
science should i do electrical
engineering or even whether medical what
lawyer all those things uh
between electrical engineering and
computer science uh my dad failed um you
don't really want to major in computer
science the computer is just a tool you
use in your whatever work um but
you don't do it for a career
so he thought what i should major in
electrical engineering you do a circuit
signal those kinds of things and you can
still use computer
now
it might be the other way around them
people choose what computer science and
then they learn all these computer
skills and then they can go to different
industries because everywhere you need
computer you need software or any kind
of things that's something i see
frequently is that you know i have a
daughter that's 17. she's looking to
enter college here soon
uh and i told her like there will never
be a shortage of software developers
right yeah yeah so it's different but
back then as i said on my dad
you shouldn't just what real-time
computer well it's just the assistant or
tool you use um right so i went to what
t1 i studied in uh electrical
engineering and then in that department
um we have like over 200 students in the
school they kind of assign you to
different classes you have what the 30
or 40ish students in one class and then
all these classes they have different
the focus areas like one one
class is more about signal processing
and the other one is more about circuit
or the other one like microwave or image
all those what are different focused
subfields or areas
and then from my class with assignment
kind of um
most of the professors we work with they
worked on signal processing pattern
recognition
communication
so that's kind of how i started with
this area and then in the final year we
needed to do a undergraduate thesis and
because of that class i was in i started
working with professors in
recognition lab
[Music]
the undergraduate thesis topic for me
was
chinese word segmentation um i don't
know if you know the language what
chinese we write without any space it's
just a sequence of characters and then
if you want to do any kind of language
processing or even speech recognition uh
you need to have this unit like word in
english you have space that's a very
good denominator you can get the words
when in chinese use a sequence of
characters you have these 10 20
characters you need to find the words
so say for example you have character a
b c d you may segment it into a b
followed by cd
two words or it may be abc as a word and
then d is another word uh so that's my
thesis what a topic i still um language
processing tasks right now
but then um the approach we use is let's
do a dictionary based approach and we
will look up what the interdiction and
see do i see word abc or do i see the
word a b
and then you can use a greedy approach
you can go with the longest word you can
find abc is the longest let's do that
one and then if d is not a word you can
go back and you can change your decision
as to a b followed by c d um so this is
very very simple approach and then we
also added like a probability what makes
the most sense and
what's a reasonable segmentation for
that context
um anyway so that's how i started i
started doing this kind of language
processing um and then
the model we used once you get the words
out you can train this thing called
language model a language model tells
you the probability of a word following
some history or following
and that's
in speech recognition
uh so after i finished my undergraduate
uh thesis um and as i said what
everything just happened naturally um
because we all can kind of have good
grades and then you just naturally
started continuing with master degree so
i continued in that same speech
recognition lab and i was working on
this speech recognition language
probably language modeling uh problem
everything was for speech recognition
and i still remember uh when we were
doing a master
research or thesis and we worked with
this company phillips
right now it's a very different company
or different world
but that's for building a lot of
vocabulary speech recognition system and
often the time we just set it in front
of the computer and you see something
that's very long and you look at the uh
transcription if the computer is
recognizing it correctly i still
remember all those demos that
vision image is still here
um
yeah so that's uh undergraduate and
master i worked out these were speech
recognition language processing problems
and then after i got my master again
it's just a natural decision everyone
came to u.s to pursue for what even
advanced degree so i came to us for phd
and then for my phd dissertation um i
worked
in this place called international
computer science institute ixe in
berkeley
the topic is
supported by darpa project
and the program was called years
this is for something called a rich
transcription of speech so you probably
know in speech recognition you have the
audio you have the speech and you need
to get the words out this is speech
recognition
but for that program in addition to
getting the correct words we want to
generate the so-called rich information
uh you need to know who is talking this
is speaker a says something this is
speaker b or what who said something
else and we also want to find a sentence
boundary when you talk you don't say
theory
uh comma uh exclamation mark everything
is kind of for the hidden implicit uh
but for
uh downstream
components to understand the speech
recognition out of it's better to have
like punctuation is if things looks like
a written language it's much easier uh
so we worked on these problems
identifying sentence boundary and also
disfluencies
in spontaneous speech people
repeat
themselves people correct themselves
people say this um ah i know you but you
know uh
um like what i'm doing right now so we
want to find all these things and clean
it up and everything will be easy for
the subsequent language processing
component and this is called rich
transcription
so that's my thesis topic sorry to
interrupt
does rich transcription also include
things like
um
sentiment analysis and emotion detection
not really not really whether that's
still focusing on just uh the surface
from getting the speech and putting
punctuation together the um additional
like discourages i mentioned and the
speaker information so that
that was what the program was about got
it because i know we have things uh
specifically with alexa that offer for
example speaker recognition right who is
the person talking was any of your
research part of
where we i know that was early on in
your phd years but um was uh was was any
of that a basis for some of the work
that we've done to
enable
i think so whether that's not my work
but we have what we had colleagues we
who also worked there in this what up
our ears program and that problem you
mentioned the speaker recognition um
it's called the speaker diarization when
you have a multi-party meeting then you
need to know who spoke and when
and the approach they developed right
now is already 15 with almost
15 17 weather years ago
it was the basis for a lot of the things
we are using now not just we and also
the entire community
one of my kind of mentor or co-advisors
for my um phd thesis
back then in berkeley ixi
his name is andres stokey and right now
he also works at um
alexa and his doing all these weather a
speech recognition speaker direction
problem
very very cool
uh and so
uh
you've obviously had a rich history in
uh in voice and speech
um how long have you been at amazon at
alexa
uh two years so we can continue that
random
oh after i got my what a phd and again i
just feels well natural i want to
continue with the research and i just
started my academic career um i went to
the university of texas at dallas as a
faculty member
so i supervise the students there and we
work on a variety of speech and language
related problems like speech recognition
modeling prosody probably means
how you talk not just of what you say
how you say things uh and then like
summarization
sentiment analysis you mentioned
um
a variety of other um problems and we
probably can touch on some of those
problems later yeah
so that's the um kind of reunion
academia working with students and
postdoc and working on all these kind of
scientifically interesting weather
problems and then after many years of
being there because kind of what family
reasons i moved to california and i
switched from academia to industry
and being in this industry i started
seeing the other side of research it's
not just for the sake of doing research
or even uh publication um
um it's mostly for
products and you want to develop things
and that will be used by millions
billions of uh users so that's that's
another one uh interesting aspect of all
these
um speech and the language technology
and i worked on um
different problems in a couple of
different companies and as you said i
joined um i was almost two years ago
yeah and you're being modest about those
other companies you've worked for right
i mean you've done time with google
you've done time with facebook
uh i mean i think those kinds of things
are really interesting to share because
it it shows that the the scientific
community is a big part of a lot of the
work that all of us are involved with
and doing and yeah i would imagine as a
researcher it's got to be really
interesting to be able to take the work
that you've done the research that
you've done and now figure out ways to
scale that to millions and billions of
people
uh because it's that's a whole different
animal than just a small subset of a
thousand or a hundred thousand yeah yeah
so that the horse size or tax size thing
whether maybe applicable here yeah when
you're trying to
scale things that can be used by all
these other um
millions millions of users and also with
some latency constraint it's a very
different problem from reading papers i
just get 10 percent improvement in some
um accuracy
um and that um
you mentioned about the different
companies so when i was at facebook and
then we were working on these natural
language processing problems
originally like when
um
i don't know if you use facebook but
when you see those recommended posts
often the time they use a lot of like
social networking information your
friends whether um have already seen
this and you probably can um
look at this post or what are some
videos uh but our focus was trying to
look at the content of that post that is
this more interesting and irrelevant to
your interests um so we were doing some
language processing finding entities and
see if this is something that's
interesting to that
user based on
his profile or the interest and the past
browsing
history um so that's a good use of all
these like
technology you just have an incredible
history this is you know 25 years of
speech and language it's amazing
yeah so congratulations on that and and
speaking of congratulations i heard that
you were recently uh named on the
international speech communication
association uh isca
um for 2021 that's that's amazing
um
yeah i guess um i can only say i'm
humbled i'm honored to get that uh
recognition
um
so
uh iska well that's community for speech
communication international speech
communication association and they do
all kinds of research related to speech
communication and that covers
phonetics like phonemes with the sounds
these kinds of things and also
linguistic information about the
language itself
of course the main part is about
uh computers what if you want to develop
all these weather systems that need to
um recognize speech and understand
speech and recognize speaker
so all these things are covered in this
community and there are also other
aspects related to even like medical
hearing aids and
speech language pathology disorders all
of those things are
part of the research topics in iska
and similar to many other scientific
communities they have this fellow
program that kind of recognize people
who have contributed significantly to
the community um and every year they
recognize
a different number of people this year i
remember i think it's eight people that
were selected to be um fellow of iska
and therefore me and my contribution is
similar to what i was telling you what
i've been doing speech recognition
understanding
prostate modeling summarization
um nlp research in general
right and and calling back to your
college degree the the degree your dad
recommended you get algo electrical
engineering uh this isn't your first uh
kind of recognition either right i mean
you're also a fellow in the ieee yeah
that happened i guess um several months
before
and if i may was
i don't know i doubt what anyone i know
is in the audience right now i i really
want to express my gratitude to all of
the people i've worked with starting
with those um people who introduced me
to the field like the people i worked
when i was undergraduate students or
professors in that speech recognition
lab and then all the way in the past
20 25 what uh years all my advisors
mentors students postdoc and colleagues
i'm even family and the friends
it's like oscar speech but
i have that feeling now um and then
related to these weather um filers i
think i often have this um what is
called imposter syndrome um and that's
also maybe because i'm one of those
minorities female and this is a problem
people talk um a lot recently and you
said that you have a daughter um i'm
hoping when the next generation when
people look at these different science
communities and then look at the other
fellows or other people they list on the
website and they will see people who are
like them and they will have less and
less
the feeling i have um i hope that's
going to be a good thing for the
community um i i know
it's rampant in the in the technology
and science communities the idea of
imposter syndrome
uh i i think it's good i um while i
don't enjoy the feeling that i get
i think it's a healthy perspective
because the opposite i've actually given
talks on this
uh is something called dunning-kruger
syndrome have you heard of that
not really like i said i don't have that
sure no you you don't at all those are
the people that believe that they are
amazing and did all the time
right so imposter syndrome is when
you're actually pretty good at something
but you don't believe it uh and dunnin
krueger is the opposite of that it's
where you believe you're very very good
and you're not uh and so um i think
imposter syndrome is okay and it's
healthy uh and i don't think that we'll
ever get beyond that because everybody
presents their their best
world right i mean it i was gonna
transition into
um you know the research papers that you
publish you've got quite a prolific
publication history
and some of the people in the chat have
actually commented that as well um
and it's it's just interesting to see if
people look across the the landscape i'm
sure they look at your work and go uh
she's amazing unbelievable all the work
that she's done all the things she's
contributed to and you sit back and say
i wish i'd done more right yeah that's a
different feeling that's the kind of
other self whether i
feel appreciation
but i i am very glad i have all those
other mentors they are super super
supportive and some of the people you
even talked to whether in this program
julia hershberger do you like a weather
tour and
yeah they
they were
supportive of all my career development
in the past and
yeah
right that's what i always say yes yeah
definitely so i'm also saying what we
should all
pay it forward and i'm also doing things
i can to help whether the next
speaking of papers let's get into one
specifically i know you just had uh
you're one of the authors accepted for a
paper interspeech
um and i'll let you talk about it but
it's leveraging asr
uh for deep entity retrieval can you can
you tell us about that
yeah so this is related to both speech
recognition and the downstream
processing uh so this is an entity
retrieval task
and i know many people use
some sort of assistance whether it's
siri alexa
google
often the time if there's an entity in
that user utterance it may not be
correctly recognized especially if it's
a rare entity you are trying to search
for a local restaurant then
these assistants haven't heard of it
you're checking whether for some
city but not very populated with a city
uh so if the entity is not correctly
recognized it's very hard for these
assistants to take action because they
need to look at the database of the
catalog and steal this is the one you're
referring to and i'm going to take some
action whether it's
returning information about that
restaurant or play the music or the song
whether on the user is asking
so what do we do when that entity is not
correctly recognized you cannot retrieve
the correct entity uh and in this
particular paper um we look at it can we
use multiple recognition output because
a speech recognition system called asr
it doesn't just return the one best
hypothesis it can also give you multiple
candidates uh this is a very old
technique like i said whether even when
we work on problems 10 or 20 years ago
everyone was looking at multiple
candidates from
esr system but here now we are in this
deep learning era and we you we were
trying to use a new technique to look at
the old problem
so we used all these neural network
methods um and then explored different
ways to represe
uh
and based hypothesis from speech
recognition system and we use all these
techniques called weather
attention deep neural network um to
determine what what is the best
representation for those investor
hypothesis um and
our results
do show when you use multiple candidates
from asr and you get much better results
than just relying on the top one
hypothesis
um yeah yeah i think that's not
surprising
as you think about no it that doesn't
seem like it's a it's surprising but it
is it is
certainly interesting to think about
that we're we're doing additional work
that the user at the end of the day may
never see
yeah but we're saying hey they said this
but it could be one of these five best
things
um and then we work through that process
uh using natural language understanding
and a number of other tools
understand what what is the actual best
out of these yeah yes so this is a
problem that's very typical for this
kind of pipeline system you have speech
recognition you have some understanding
components afterwards and therefore the
first components it doesn't provide the
right hypothesis or prediction the
second one is going to suffer and the
error is going to propagate to the next
component what do you do and you can ask
another upstream or that component for
more information and then you do your
resolution retrieval or any kind of
understanding
uh in this second subsequent components
and you will do a better job because you
have other information available like
catalog um even some user related
information
and then relate to this problem we're
talking about uh how is our errors may
affect some downstream understanding
task and if i may i just want to
advertise what is something we
are also doing so our team especially
with a scientist uh sukhum kim is the
main driver uh for this challenge we are
organizing this is one of the tracks in
this year's dialogue
system technology
talent dstc talent
we are trying to
evaluate all the conversation modeling
or the dialogue system performance using
speech interactions
a lot of the research on dialogue
recently has focused on text-based
conversations and we know when you use
dialog systems often in its speech-based
interaction and speech recognition
errors have a negative impact there so
we want to see whether in real scenarios
or what is the performance of all of
these
dialogue systems or conversation
modeling technology and we're organizing
this uh dsec challenge and how
there will be many participants uh
participating system now we can see what
um how we can
advance the technology
yeah that's that's excellent i actually
just shared a link to that directly with
our audience so
hopefully we'll have a few people check
out that challenge that's very very
interesting
um
speaking of papers another topic that
you've been covering lately is common
sense inference for smooth and effective
communication
um can you can you help me understand
kind of what that means
yeah it's a very hard problem uh so we
were just talking about uh some very
specific a task or into the conversation
but you want to check the weather you
want to play some music and that's all
that's going into the conversation and
this common sense related work is for
open domain conversations this is like
for chatbot uh social work um recently
this is very very good there are a lot
of research in the science community and
you probably have seen some
announcements from
different companies google has a chatbot
called mina facebook has one called
blenderbot and baidu has one called
plato
everyone is investing um in this area
using all these large pre-trained models
to build the open domain conversation or
dialogue systems
but the technology is not ready yet
there are a lot of problems in these
neural generation approaches the system
may not be consistent with itself
it says something in one turn and then
the next turn and we'll see a
contradiction there it may repeat the
information it has just said in the
previous term it may give you something
that's not effectually correct
and you were talking about empathy the
system doesn't show whether the correct
empathy when you are sad and they still
says oh wow that is very exciting tone
so to address these problems in the
research community over the time people
because we're using all these machine
learning models so they start trying
to get appropriate data to train models
to address those specific problems i
mentioned
whether it's factory correctness or
empathy or consistency problem but
there's one aspect that hasn't been
studied
a bit for this open domain conversation
and that is common sense um so i can
give you an example if i tell my friend
or i'm going to have a live interview
tomorrow with jeff and this alexa and
the french
thing um
his or her reaction maybe
but don't worry you will you will do a
very well because my person probably
knows i'm going to get nervous because
it's a live event um so this kind of
implicit common sense reasoning um it's
not very well modeled in the current
neural network um based approach and
that's what we were trying to do
so how do we do this
it's very interesting to approach that
because it we we call it common sense as
if all humans should just know that this
is something that's natural and obvious
yeah that's why it's called common sense
and these things are implicated it
doesn't say oh i think you are nervous
and i'm going to say oh don't worry then
you will do just the word well um
how do we get that the implicit part and
how can we get the appropriate data sets
or copra to train all these models so
that's how we would have started and we
thought oh we need a data center to do
this kind of thing where do we get this
kind of social related reactions or
conversation or dialogues so we started
with something called social iqa and
from the name you may people tell it's
related to social events um that's the
data set collected by whether some folks
at lnai and other
places um i can give you a scenario or
example in that data set um
example says alex or jeff spill the
weather spaghetti or food on the floor
what is this person going to do
and there are multiple uh choices there
this person is doing more pop or clean
the floor and this person is going to
eat the food this person is going to run
around and play in the mess so we want
to see whether um
when this data center was developed it's
meant to see if machines can do this
kind of common sensor even handle some
um social events and
and we thought oh that seems a good um
starting point for us to collect the
related conversational dialogue so we
use those scenarios or contacts in
social iqa dataset and we ask the crowd
workers to write a conversation about
that or i spilled the food and then your
friends may say oh let's clean it up
your friends may say oh no food unless
all the pizza so these are all like
natural uh reaction and they kind of
capture this kind of common sense what
we're talking about
um and we collected this data set and
right now it's in the final processing
we do want to release to the entire
research community it should be out
pretty soon
and in that paper we look at it
using
these neural methods trained using the
data set that we collected and also some
other existing data sets then we showed
what a good performance when you use
these
more like a common sense related
conversation or dialogue
very cool so
our audience has already mentioned one
of these
um but the the question i want to ask
you next is about the hard challenges
what are the really big problems that
you're facing as you get into this
and so in the dialog system space what
what are the big problems the one that
was mentioned in the chat was the idea
of sarcasm
uh i know that that's a very big
challenge in i think that is
well when uh when you think about
your big challenges that you face what
are the things that stand out to you
um
yeah so it's not one challenge i do want
to mention multiple challenges and then
those two papers so we talk about the
two different kinds of conversational
dialogue system one is task oriented one
we know right now all these um
assistants they do pretty well for a
very specific task of playing music
check weather or even multi-term
conversation if you need to make a hotel
um
restaurant the reservation with a few
turns the system can get the information
they need and they can complete that
transactional um
finish the task
but that's that's all what the current
system can do um the conversation is
quite rigid you cannot go whether all
that pre-defined schema or intents and
entities laws um so how do we scale up
two different scales so different tasks
how can we allow users to say things in
a more natural water way rather than
just the completing uh or providing the
agents with the information the agent is
asking
how can we treat models using what the
less data we don't want to collect the
hundreds of weather or even thousands
millions of utterances for each of those
tasks we are uh doing uh these are all
challenges for that task or into the
conversation and then the other
side of that spectrum is the one we were
just talking about this open domain
conversation if you want to have a
chatbot that can talk to you about
pretty much any type of paper there's no
way you can write these predefined
prompts or responses for each of those
topics right we cannot even list all of
the possible topics so all these
neural network-based approaches they are
very promising they you don't have this
constraint you're only covering certain
number of topics
but as i was saying the current
technology is still far far away from
human performance whether uh from
rather
getting a good reaction from the users
yeah
i think that makes sense that sounds a
lot like um what we're going to talk
about next which is the alexa prize
um i mean that that contest is kind of
tailored around that open domain idea
right where indeed yeah
the competitors um who i think the most
recent winner was the the
but so i would imagine you probably have
more to share on that but i'd love your
perspective on the alexa prize and the
competition and kind of the goals that
are that are out there to to do that
okay that's good well just in case
whether people don't know about this um
alexa price uh one of the
kind of tracks in alexa price is this
social world grand challenge this
started a few years back i think it's
2016.
amazon alexa started this competition
with the goal to
help advance the field of conversation
ai
and then
the task is for the university teams to
build these so-called social worlds or
chat laws uh that interact with the real
alexa customers if you have
a device at a
chat and you will be talking to these
social workers developed by university
teams
the ultimate goal for this alexa price
surfboard competition is to get a score
of 4 out of 5
from judges
when you have these open domain
conversations at the end you're going to
read the well how did the conversation
go and then you gave a kind of a subject
they would score
um and in terms of the length the goal
is also to have a conversation with a
minimum 20 minutes this is very hard and
as i was telling you right now all the
approaches we use
um you see all those repetition
contradictions incorrectly all these
things so
if you have a 20 minutes conversation
you're going to see all those problems
it's very hard to have a four or five
with a score on the other five right if
you have a long conversation
so we haven't uh yeah we haven't met
that goal yet and this is the end of the
competition all right you and i have
been talking almost 40 minutes i wonder
what the judges would think in chris 49
i think it's very natural and then
because
with what we were just doing this kind
of
turn taking back channel and then
interruption we still handle it very
well right you were trying to say
something and i will see if i should eat
over the floor and let you talk
in the current weather path that's
that's very hard um
um
yeah but there are other problems so i
was just saying we haven't met that goal
yet and this year's competition this is
the end of the fourth year uh check it
with the university this is the first
place followed by stanford university
and university of um
buffalo
um after four years
many many university teams were
attempting we haven't met that goal and
that tells you this is indeed a very uh
challenging uh problems but we also see
a lot of good progress from these
university teams in the past years they
have been increasing the coverage of the
topics the system can um have a
conversation with the university about
the universe the conversations are
getting more and more engaging and
especially this year a lot of the
university teams are exploring
the neural network weather-based
approaches for generation
so they don't need to write all of those
rule-based template-based responses for
different domains um so i'm hoping to
see what a more advanced you were
from all these teams but i think that's
how we grow right we have to do a lot of
it manually first and then we look at
ways to kind of consolidate and grow
those manual processes into machine
learning operations i think that's
it's natural to try to progress that way
and this this is it's interesting to see
that we're starting to pivot and turn
towards a more normal approach
and the good thing whether for these
competition is
these university teams or the social
boss they are using alexa customers to
get they get the real data this is very
different from the research they do in
the university lab uh
setting oh i'm going to recruit 10 or 20
people or maybe what a crowd worker a
hundred of other people and try this
system i'm developing so every day they
get a lot of conversation real
conversations and then at the end they
gather the ratings from real users and
they also get some virtual
verbal feedback about the conversation
that's very useful for the university
teams to
improve or continue to develop their
systems
this is a very good opportunity amazon
provided to the university
yes
uh for any of you that want to try this
if you're not aware you can talk to any
alexa device that you own uh and i won't
say uh the name but you can say let's
chat yes and that will randomly choose a
chatbot for you and you can try to have
some of those conversations with these
university projects it's a really fun
way to
try and have a long conversation with an
ai
yeah and there's also a new competition
that has just started this year so i was
saying that's the track one in alexa
price the new competition is a task
board this is different from the open
domain conversation the taskbar is meant
to help customers who
finish some tasks and we're looking at
what are two tasks one is the home
improvement the diy i know a lot of
people are probably interested in that
and the other one is cooking if you want
to bake a cake and then you can ask
alexa to help you with those different
steps
so this is the other competition on
right now ten university
teams are participating uh in this
competition and i remember the task both
will be available to the customers later
this year i don't remember the exact
date
yeah so it will be very interesting to
see this new
um competition this is
uh multi-modal one not like the first
one you have an echo show device and you
will see whether image or video that
tells you the steps you need to do for
that diy or cookie
that's exciting uh
very cool
uh all right we're gonna get back to
more papers you've written because
you've written so many uh but one of the
things i'd like to ask about is um a
paper you recently co-authored about the
growing popularity of virtual assistants
and uh one of the things that's near and
dear to me as an alexa skill builder uh
is the idea of entity resolution so can
you go into more detail about what that
paper entailed oh yeah i can briefly
mention it
so this is what a recent paper is you
said it's about entity resolution and
this is for alexa shopping application
um when you talk to alexa you can say um
add milk to my shopping cart what does
milk mean when you say milk and you
probably are thinking about a
particularly
brand or that milk maybe you ordered uh
last week so we need to resolve that
entity we need to find or drink the list
of of the relevant entities how do we do
that
we have
users
history information we can use based on
the products you have already purchased
we also have descriptions for different
products attributes of other products
so we look at all these uh
kinds of information and again we use
deep learning graph representation to
kind of merge these things together to
find a good ranked list of relevant
product users
that's a short description
uh very cool and i i think um those are
the kinds of things that we just take
for granted right because
in the example you used add milk to my
cart
um yeah milk can eat a lot of things do
i mean almond milk do i mean uh normal
milk do you wanna get any milk a
different particular brand anything yes
yeah so people do all these things and
everything is kind of uh implicit
um i didn't mention one earlier when we
were talking about the common sense
reasoning uh in that conference where we
present the paper there's another paper
they are also doing things similar so
example in that paper is oh the view is
so pretty
and then the expectation is the
assistant is going to ask you do you
want me to turn the camera app on
so user may say things in a very
implicit way but hoping the
smart intelligent assistance is going to
take the right action figuring out that
uh transaction right
we do need to use a lot of rich
information to do this like the new
example i can have a collection of the
milk and for every meal i have the
description there
i can also find similar customers to you
and then first
find some similar ingredients similar
shared
common things between the products you
have
to do this kind of
reason
i
i have to say
one of my favorite parts about having
these conversations is getting a view
into the the future that you see
uh right because as you work on your
research you know what is eventually
possible although it's not necessarily
possible today yeah
you have these big dreams these big
ideas that uh that are in your head
about how things should work and how
they will go
um and oftentimes they're just patterned
off of what we see with natural human
interactions or whatever
um but that is one of my favorite parts
about having these kinds of interviews
is that i get to i get to see inside
your head a little and understand um
just the the nuance of being able to sit
and see a beautiful mountain range uh
and just by saying something you just
imagine that your camera will turn on
and record some of that for you or take
a picture
i absolutely love that
yeah i think whether the product manager
or those pms and collect the more
requests whether from the users and
alexa now we can do these uh working
backwards from the user's needs request
and then we'll see how we can close that
gap and work out the technology
so so we've talked a lot about your
career and certainly a lot of the work
that you've done recently
um is is there something that stands out
to you as kind of your biggest
accomplishment in your career so far
oh that's an easy question that's a
short answer i think whether like as a
parent in the most uh
um what the the thing you are proud of
it's probably some achievement from your
children i don't know if that's how you
feel um so looking back when my career i
think what the uh the most uh rewarding
thing is seeing some achievements from
the people i have mentored like
knowing some achievements from former
students of course there will be people
i mentor whether in the company um yeah
there's no doubt about that i still get
messages or emails from people i've
worked with or former students and they
tell me or i get promoted i just became
associate professor oh i'm invited to
give a keynote talk in this conference
that's i think that's the most rewarding
moment i i would agree with you i think
that that's that's often overlooked
though i think a lot of people view
uh being someone that offers mentoring
uh as as oh that's extra work or i don't
i don't want to do that stuff but the
reward that you get on the other side
seeing people successful because they
took your guidance your advice
um
because that's uh we often say at amazon
you know trying to find a way to scale
through others
and um it's it's interesting to me to
think about that perspective that if if
you go off and do your work in uh in a
vacuum by yourself
your your capacity is limited but if you
spread that knowledge and spread that
experience across a number of people
that are coming up
now your work is not only taking place
in front of you but in front of dozens
of other people as well so i that's a
great way
yeah that will be a better world
yeah
i agree um
all right so i i also noticed uh in your
bio
that it lists the air force young
investigator program
uh and the nsf career award i um i'd
love to know about this air force young
investigator program this this sounds
interesting
um yeah so these um defense agencies
including
air force army
navy department defense they all have
this young investigator program yep
award and the program is meant to
support
people who are in their early career
development typically the rule is it's
five years after you get your phd and
then you are qualified for this
award and the goal is to of course help
these um
early career development of these
whatever outstanding uh uh investigators
or scientists uh they also tries to
increase the opportunity for these
scientists to recognize or understand
the needs from these agencies the
research problems they care about
of course there's another fundamental
objective to just support the basic
research in all kinds of areas in
science and technology
and i think every year at least for air
force typically 30 to 40-ish scientists
um are selected every year for this yap
uh award
um so i got the
award um
2009 2010 yeah a long time ago
but my fun day the research from air
force
was about emotion recognition in speech
so when we're saying things and i want
to know whether you are happy angry and
there is a notion in the community and
you probably will agree with me
there is some universal
aspect
even if you don't know the language you
probably can roughly tell this person is
angry sad or happy
and there's also some culture specific
part so we want to look at this from
both um
across culture and also universal
weather thing and see if we can build a
cross-lingual
emotion recognition systems
so the first paper we did
for that fun day the research
is looking at the cross-lingual
emotional recognition in both automatic
systems as well as human perception and
we recruited the people who were native
chinese speakers and native english
speakers and we play the
chinese english and german different
speech with different emotions and we
were looking at how people perceive this
emotional speech
in their native language and also in
language they don't know
and of course we also did the automatic
part and we train the system using one
language and we evaluate the system
using the other language and of course
this all happened before the deep
learning um
got so prevalent
it was using the old classification
approach like support vector machines
those kinds of things but the general
message is probably um still
applicable right now uh if you look at
all these automatic systems they suffer
quite a bit if you train the system
using one language and you evaluate the
system on the other language and you see
a lot of degradation but if you look at
a human perception there's a little bit
of degradation but not a whole lot we
can still get some
universal um cues about the emotion
um i'm thinking another
um
finding not from us is between the
visual cues and the speech um there's
more universal ones from the video one
like if you watch a movie or a video
speaking in another language i don't
know what languages you speak of but
maybe what imagine this chinese
just looking at the characters with a
facial expression and listening to their
speech you probably can get the
character is happy angry
but i think most of the information
comes from um
the vd1 um
there's speech you probably can tell
when people shout and they're maybe um
for sure that may be a good idea
research done about are there any
specific languages or cultures that
don't map well to that like is we talk
about like the sound of anger is pretty
universal across languages but are are
there places or
dialects or languages where that is not
true
i don't know the answer to that like a
question yeah
based on the literature we did back then
but those probably um were all the
languages that were widely studied in
the research community this is also
related to the law resource language
problem maybe there are things out there
that we don't quite know um yeah so i
don't i don't have a lot of information
about those kinds of languages yeah
that's that's a good question
yeah definitely
i think that um it would be it would be
odd if we found like a small tribe
someplace that uh their anger sounded
like laughter or something
yeah probably unlikely and honestly as
our globe continues to get smaller and
smaller and we get exposed to more and
more uh other cultures just right
radio internet uh i think that we will
find more and more it's very different
and maybe going back to that super power
well
i had if people can express the things
in the right way to the audience and
then will
have no miscommunication at all even
though you are using a weird
original other intentional language
we are almost out of time i have one
more question for you uh before we wrap
up here uh i know that a lot of the
folks that are in our audience um might
still be in school uh we're pursuing a
lot of the careers that we've been
talking about some of their research and
industries
uh and so i'd really be curious do you
have any advice for people that are
looking for careers in speech or natural
language processing
um
i sort of do
i'm not good at giving what otherwise
but as you said that since i have these
years of experiences i do have some tips
uh so first i want to say what if you
are interested in audience what weather
featuring videos technology you are in a
very good time right now and this is a
very well this is growing field and
there are a lot of interesting problems
out there and some challenges we
mentioned uh earlier and you have data
and you have weather um
computing what the resources and there
are also a lot of tools um open source
stuff up there so it's very easy to get
into the field but then once you start
that's what i meant what i do have a few
tips so in terms of the technical part
um i think it's good for everyone to
build a very good foundation so this
requires the breadth and depth of your
knowledge uh and if we can use
the technology we talked about the
weather previously so just take speed or
language as a example we were using
something called the hidden markov model
hmm for speech recognition and then that
technique was adopted in many other
natural language problems in speech not
speech recognition in machine
translation in particular tagging
another example is
this thing called the convolutional
neural network it was developed in
computer vision but then it was also
adopted in natural language processing
for
text classification to find out what a
sentiment to find the topic of different
articles
so these are just examples if you
know
more and you also get inspired from
similar or other fields um this requires
quite some breadth of the knowledge
and then for the depth part you really
need to have a good understanding for
that particular problem you are working
on uh you don't want to just report oh
i'm getting um 10 better with accuracy
than some previously published uh
personal results you need to ask
yourself a few questions why uh what
findings you are getting uh what do the
results mean uh what are the
contributions from different components
so this requires some deep understanding
and in amazon we have a
leadership principle called dive deep
this is what every scientist or every
person who is working out is what
scientific problems needs to have
and of course the rest is all about the
general uh problem-solving skill uh in
universities or maybe whether in your
lab setting uh some people have already
formulated the problem for you you have
a data set and you just need to develop
some models uh
to
try to get a better performance but in
real world you need to formulate that
problem yourself maybe you need to
collect your data you need to define
your metric
so it requires a lot of these problem
solving skill
and then what else is important software
skills collaborating with other people
uh having open minded um
um
uh have a good network all these things
are extremely uh important so i think
it's funny how often we have to tell
people and i mean we just in the global
we
that working with and collaborating with
people um is something that you need to
be good at
um because so many people that just want
to live in their own box and do their
own thing
and the the growth the knowledge and the
the the big leaps in in anything uh came
from people working together
uh my mind goes off sometimes too it's
quite all right yeah maybe that's why i
mentioned one of those ducks or horses
that you're going to collaborate that's
the first weather reaction when you have
a team and then what yeah you need to
work
very well with the others
i heard uh depth i heard problem solving
and i heard collaboration i think those
are all positive strengths for anybody
that's thinking about getting into both
science or technology at all
um all right well yang i want to thank
you so much for being here today
for all of you that are watching if you
want to see any of
the papers that we've been discussing or
anything you can go to amazon.science to
check out
her research as well as everyone else's
in our amazon science organization there
there's also inner speech 2021 page
and you can find all the research papers
from this year's conference there
um i really really appreciate uh the
fact that you're willing to take the
time to share your knowledge and
experience with all of us
uh it goes a long way and uh based on
the conversations i'm seeing in the chat
um you know you've you've certainly
inspired some people to take the next
steps and what they're thinking about
too so thank you so much for being here
thank you for having me
certainly all right i'm gonna leave all
of you with a short video uh all about
working in the amazon science
organization um but thank you guys all
for tuning in this is the end of the
stream and we will see you all again
next time
my name is ola banji shonibar i am an
applied scientist at amazon i work with
the pro language understanding service
and response team within alex's speech
my name is aparna and i'm a senior
applied scientist in the alexa speech
recognition currently i'm working on
building better experiences